bugs aren't really attracted to
artificial light they're confused by it
researchers at Imperial College London
used high resolution motion capture and
stereo videography to reconstruct the 3D
kinematics of bugs flying around light
bulbs they discovered the insects don't
steer toward the light what's actually
happening is they turn their backs to
the light because doing that during the
natural Skylight helps Orient their
flight path so it seems like artificial
lights are trapping insects in a drunken
flight pattern not sucking them in like
a mesmerizing sexy tractor beam Vsauce
one story down seven to go this is mind
blow the next Global virus might come
from a diaper babies are poop machines
and it turns out their diapers are full
of scientific Secrets University of
Copenhagen microbiologists spent five
years analyzing the poop of over 600
babies and they found that every crappy
nappy was home to over 10 000 virus
species the researchers found thousands
of never before seen viruses deep in the
dookie including over 200 brand new
families of viruses ninety percent of
the viruses were bacteria killers and
that offers insight into how our immune
systems develop and it might eventually
help us combat chronic illnesses like
asthma and diabetes the next time your
little cousin reeks remember that his
pant load contains about number two to
the 14th power different genetically
simple organisms Albert Einstein just
discovered a massive black hole from
Beyond the Grave Einstein predicted the
phenomenon of gravitational lensing when
an object is so gigantic that it
literally curves the fabric of space to
bend light around it and it works like a
huge space warping telephoto lens a team
at Durham University and the Max Planck
Institute harness gravitational lensing
to find a black hole with 30 billion
times more mass than our sun it lives in
the Galaxy called
abel1201 but relax you're not going to
get sucked in it's 2.7 billion light
years away toss in this freshly
sharpened image of the first photo ever
taken of another black hole and it's a
good time for black hole news plants
that get a spritz of anti-drought
perfume can help at least 55 million
people every year drought is actually
the most deadly of all natural disasters
and when crops die from lack of water
people go hungry researchers at
universities Valencia have created a
spray-on drug that activates a plant's
natural defenses against drought the
plants consume 30 percent less water and
they can even go without any water for
longer it just sprays on from a bottle
so anyone can do it and it's already
been tested successfully on tomato
plants now we just need a spray bottle
the size of the Eastern Hemisphere
hardcore Chad Vsauce 2 fans will know
I've recently started exercising but my
potato chip casserole dinner doesn't
mesh with a workout routine thankfully
America's number one Ready-to-Eat meal
kit is delivering fresh never froze
meals to my door and seriously it's like
a slice of cyberpunk futurism to have
Chef prepared sun-dried tomato chicken
on your doorstep and ready to eat after
120 seconds of reflecting microwaves
causing water molecules to vibrate to
produce heat inside your fresh delicious
food Factor has plans like calorie smart
keto Protein Plus or Chef's Choice
whatever fits your personal goals and
tastes and it's all dietitian approved
so whether you're trying to cut back on
takeout or just want nutritious meals
ready in two minutes without any prep
mess or trips to the grocery store
factor is an unbelievable value and
service so I had to factor75.com or
click the link below and use code
vsauce250 to get 50 off your first
Factor box thanks to them for sponsoring
vsauce2 that's factor75.com and code
vsauce250 for 50 off your first Factor
box brain scans are now sharper 64
million times sharper researchers from
multiple universities came together led
by Duke Center for in Vivo microscopy to
develop an absolutely massive MRI
resolution upgrade they accomplished
this Ultra sharp Mouse brain scan in
part by utilizing a much stronger Tesla
magnet a 100 times boost with special
gradient coils and a massive computer
processing Improvement the hope is to
obviously study the brain in previously
impossible detail make the MRI even
stronger and eventually lead to
breakthroughs in Alzheimer's research as
well as just helping humans live longer
and healthier lives which seems helpful
the fruit in your garbage can dissolve
Lithium-ion batteries engineers at
nanyang Technological University in
Singapore mixed shredded batteries with
solvents derived from fruit Peels and it
actually recycles them by extracting
Cobalt lithium and nickel fruit peels
are rich in sugars flavonoids and
phenolic acids which dissolve and
recover the metals this is not just a
thing in a lab they've scaled it up to a
working plant that can recycle 2 000
liters of dead batteries and it all also
works with leftover pineapples pears and
lemons in the Great War of fruit garbage
versus battery garbage The Winner Is Us
it turns out a good gift to bring in
Egypt was severed hands we knew about
the practice known as gold of Honor from
tomb inscriptions Egyptian warriors
would present the hands of defeated
enemies to the Pharaoh and in return
he'd give them gold necklaces and golden
pendants shaped like flies
archaeologists uncovered a heap of 18
hands that are the first real evidence
of this practice and they were easily
visible from the throne room which
suggests the Pharaoh really liked
looking at them which means if we ever
invent time machines and you end up
going to a pyramid warming well you know
what to bring everything you need to
make the next generation of Bio
adhesives is probably in your kitchen a
team at The terasaki Institute for
biomedical innovation in Los Angeles has
developed a bioadhesive with better
sticking strength stretch ability and
toughness than what we've got now and
they made it from ingredients found in
coffee olive oil and gel wounds that
reopen after surgery are extremely
dangerous for some procedures the
mortality rate is 45
stitches and Staples alone just fail too
often the new adhesive is three times
stickier than previous wound sealants
and the gel can even hold and release
medicines like antibiotics directly onto
the wound caffeic acid is found in all
plants and it's a critical ingredient in
Woody plant biomass it makes sense that
it could give structural superpowers to
gelatin oh and kathyic acid is also a
precursor to the building blocks of
lignin not to be confused with the
notoriously dangerous medical condition
known as ligma and now how to connect to
the micronet 800 in 1984.
um the telephone is connected to the
telephone network with the British
Telecom plug and I simply remove the
telephone jack from the Telecom socket
plug it into this box here the modem I
then take another wire from the modem
and plug it in where the telephone was
and it is now telling me to phone up the
main Presto computer I'm now waiting for
the computer to answer me it asks with a
tone and things are starting to happen
things are starting to happen
[Music]
oh